the highest paying entry-level jobs a
lot of people out there saying i'm
losing i'm moving jobs i'm graduating
college i'm starting a new career where
do i go where do i go and there's seven
the seven highest paying entry-level
jobs we'll start with number seven and
work our way to the top of the mountain
numero siete as they say so these are
the seven highest paying entry-level
jobs
number seven
an accountant
entry level average annual salary is 46
um
everything that you do with accounting
you know you're managing finances you're
doing taxes you're you know maybe you're
heading up to payroll in your department
you're doing all that kind of stuff like
that there's pros and cons with that you
have any quick thoughts on what it's
like to be an accountant um i can say
that it's probably not the most exciting
job ever no it's not
it doesn't get your heart beating fast
and at least not my heartbeat in fact
you're a numbers guy maybe the numbers
got maybe but you know you start
somewhere you work your way to the top
an accountant number seven on the list
of best entry-level jobs that pay the
most 46 gs not a bad place to start
number six if you love animals this
one's for you veterinarian average
annual sale salary of 48 000
so this is after you know after
attending school to become a vet you
don't just walk into a job and become a
vet so basically
number six forty eight thousand dollars
um you love animals you love saving
animals you love helping animals you
like helping the longevity of animals
live forever that's the upside down side
you're dealing with a lot of crap
there's a lot of crap involved in that
literal crap but but some job security
right people love to keep their animals
alive they're trying to make them live
longer that's true you know if people
could
you know make their dogs live forever i
think they might invest in that that's
true that's true still
a lot of crap
uh number five on this list is an hr
manager that stands for human resources
manager their average annual salary
starts
at 52 000 not bad hr managers are in
charge of recruiting interviewing and
hiring new employees for their company
we all know hr the last thing you want
to do is
get sent to hr's office right excuse me
hr is going to want to speak with you we
actually have a great hr person here
yeah so respect our guy robert here it
is the principal's office of the
corporate environment 100
they're going to need you in hr
they're going to need your name and then
everybody around you goes oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
toby in the office is the hr guy
everybody hates talking
toby shoot me right now dude
toby for the office
anyway he's the party pooper that guy
right if you are gonna get into hr you
have to be okay with pooping on the
party that's true number four on this
list is a web developer a web developer
starts at 58 000 you might have heard
things are moving pretty nicely for the
web these days things are on the web
we're on the web right now i want to say
currently
that just happened so they're making
some money out there on the web you know
reputation wise
sort of a nerd but not these days no i
don't think we're nerds i don't think
you're a nerd no i don't think these two
over here are nerds none of us are web
developers
that's true none of us code
a web developer yeah mark zuckerberg yes
not you know
time magazine hottest most sexiest man
of all time
is there any chance you've been friends
with mark zuckerberg in high school
definitely not that i would be nice to
him you'd be friends with him now that'd
be nice to him just
you know what you know he should be nice
to
everyone
but everyone especially people that are
like dedicated to something mark was so
obsessed with coding i'd be like bro
you're like an athlete when it comes to
coding yeah and i respect that the the
days of the jocks and the nerds are done
oh yeah
everybody's on computers these days tech
is taking over back in you know the 80s
you know look at these nerds on
computers freaking nerds it's like yeah
uh everybody's on a computer these days
guys oh you don't have a computer there
right
captain of the varsity
football team yeah uh you can borrow
mine you don't know how to set up your
icloud
let's get these nerds
paul you were a jock you were probably
nice to the to the nerds back in school
yeah i was yes
i was in all their classes sick sick
input but i was a scholar athlete there
adam i know you were i tried to you know
give you a layup right there
speaking of tell my gp i don't you do
that
you do great paul
um you said you want to tell your gpa no
i don't need to oh okay
paul
uh number three on this list after a web
developer number three is an
occupational therapist right their
average annual salary starts at 65 000.
now we're starting to make some decent
money here now we're starting to to
really get in there an occupational
therapist you'll work with patients who
are injured or disabled to help them do
everyday activities there's a lot of
rewarding
benefits
to being an occupational therapist
people get injured people need help
you're really you're really doing some
decent stuff what you got something to
say somebody in the comments said uh pbd
would bully adam in high school
do you think do you think people do you
think you and ppb would be homies in
high school we're homies now we would
have been homies back then we're homies
no matter what cool all right what's
funny is i would have probably
met pat and took him under my wing don't
forget this guy was new to the country
all right he maybe didn't speak with the
best accent right i was like who's this
6-3 stud this guy's going to be on my
team okay we're going to do we're going
to do some work right we're going to hit
the club to get we would have been we
would have been amigos yeah maybe the
best padres maybe the best thing that
happened to him is that he met you now
yeah maybe that's the best thing that
happened to pat is he didn't meet me in
high school yeah exactly pat we're going
to the club dude i got to read we're
going to the freaking club
you know he tells this story all the
time yeah pat we're going to the club no
i got to read i'm like bro i'm outside
your house right now there's two girls
in the car we're going to the club
yeah all right sauce
anyway so where are we at that's number
three occupational therapist right there
number two
which i have a major affinity to in my
life is
a registered nurse registered nurse
these people are fantastic their average
annual salary starts at 61 000
obviously we all know about nurses
they're heroes these days especially
during covid they're out there saving
lives they are
what are called essential workers they
are essential they are heroes
and a lot of them quite frankly are very
lovely ladies there's some male nurses
out there some nurses
but the ladies god bless you i've i have
some good friends
some lady friends that are nurses and
they are they're they're awesome they
are attractive they are beautiful
they've got kind hearts they do it all
they look good while doing it god bless
the nurses i got a soft spot for nurses
you're a guy that likes to be taken care
of is what it seems like here
not bad nurses all right
so you're helping people you're saving
lives and you've got some good job
security and number one and it's not
even freaking close yeah so number two
was a nurse who starts at sixty 61 000
number one
drum roll
i don't even know what the hell this is
but damn they're making money is a data
scientist a data scientist starts
entry-level position making 93 000 a
year that's a lot of money they're
killing it out there data scientist
helps a company strategize the next
steps by analyzing data
and industry trends now here's the big
question do you say data or data um i
say
data
data yeah well maybe i say data i say
data you say tomato i say right whatever
i have some value here yes do you know
who's a a data scientist or who was a
data data scientist data data data data
jeff bezos okay i can see that jeff
bezos the way that he figured out what
amazon was going to be is he was working
at a quantitative analysis firm yeah and
he saw how fast the internet was growing
and he decided to start selling books on
the internet that's where amazon started
so
bezos started as a data scientist and
now look at him the richest man of all
time listen let me tell you something
the new currency these days
data data data
that is the new currency of these data
data i agree
so um and these are the majors you have
to do if you want to be a data scientist
you got to do either computer science or
statistics to be in that industry that's
what happens
and they they're analyzing data and
industry trends that's what they do and
the rewards of doing this is they learn
about what makes businesses
tick like tik tok
that's you're going to need some data
scientists there's some tick tock you
make good money and you can network the
hell out of it we got a guy in the
comments here he goes i am a data data
scientist for apple
wow we have a data scientist for apple
nc styles i would love to know
um
what he makes what he makes hey mr nc
styles
how much money are you making my friend
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
sazcast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken